turning to politics and president biden
who is hitting the road ahead of the
coming midterms with a stark new message
among the events a prime time address on
thursday outside philadelphia's
independence hall on what the white
house is calling quote the continued
battle for the soul of the nation close
quote mr biden is expected to argue that
democracy itself is on the ballot in
november ed o'keefe is at the white
house for us once again ed good morning
tony good to see you you know we haven't
seen much of the president in recent
weeks between his bout with covet 19 his
own two-week summer vacation and the
fact that the fbi searches former
president donald trump's florida state's
been dominating the headlines but the
current president is back hitting the
road today and headed to a state that he
believes is key to democratic chances of
winning in november
president biden is gearing up for a busy
fall travel schedule designed to tout
his party's accomplishments and to state
the obvious there's a lot at stake mr
biden's travels begin today with the
first of three stops he'll make in
pennsylvania in the next week
democrats believe the keystone states
open races for senate and governor plus
several competitive house races are key
to their chances this november
in wilkes-barre today the president is
scheduled to speak on crime and gun
violence i'm determined to ban assault
weapons in this country
then thursday he's set to deliver a
prime time address outside
philadelphia's independence hall on the
continued battle for the soul of the
nation and on labor day the president
will visit pittsburgh
that day he'll also stop in wisconsin
and later next week ohio two more big
senate and gubernatorial battlegrounds
as the fall campaign begins the future
of abortion rights is emerging as a big
motivator likely voters say their vote
for congress this year will be to
support abortion rights rather than
oppose them blake masters has made his
dangerous ideas on abortion easy to
understand democrats are now filling the
airwaves with ads targeting republicans
on the issue the supreme court supported
by republicans just overturned roe
versus wade endangering women's health
care choice across america and that has
republicans like washington state
candidate tiffany smiley trying to
preempt democratic attacks
i'm pro-life but i oppose a federal
abortion ban
now it's important to point out our poll
also finds that the top issue of concern
remains the economy and inflation that's
why you're going to hear republican
candidates predominantly talking about
issues of dollars and cents democrats
will do it too but they'll point out
that inflation's starting to ease the
unemployment rate's in good shape and
they'll also of course tony continue
talking about those issues of social
concern including abortion rights
let's talk about the overall issue of
the president's approval rating in the
state of pennsylvania where he was born
and partially raised it is not only
below 50 it is below 40 according to a
recent poll so yep two critical races
there for senate and governor but i
guess the calculation is he's going to
make a difference in the positive way
why is he going there now well he's been
to pennsylvania more than a dozen times
as president it's a place he goes often
to discuss politics part of what they're
trying to do here at the white house is
boost his standing among democrats
overall part of the reason his numbers
have slipped so much is because his
numbers slipped with democrats and so if
he can bring those back up our
battleground tracker shows this as well
then his numbers overall improve that's
why you're seeing him talk in the next
week about three issues important to
democratic voters gun control and a ban
on assault weapons the fate of democracy
and then workers issues when he's in
pittsburgh on labor day you bring up the
numbers among democrats you boost his
numbers you hopefully boost democratic
turnout white house hopes that's the key
to victory in november
all right we'll be following it ed thank
you very much